di stare un modulo fidanzata oggi a
grandissima richiesta di gameplay
giocheremo a di sottile skate i ceri
anche con l'ex marito ex fidanzato gli
spiriti c'è un livello di san valentino
è anche mamma virtuale mi piace
tantissimo quindi mettetevi comodi e
continuiamo il gioco di che personaggio
dei videogiochi 6
questa volta abbiamo dei personaggi di
merton e l'altra volta se non avete
partecipato al gioco funziona così
lascia non mi piace qui sotto è l'ultima
cifra del mi piace corrisponde al
personaggio che siete qua quindi ad
esempio se vuole essere un mi piace il
vostro mi piace numero 1056 l'ultima
cifra il 6 quindi voi siete il 6 quindi
cliccate mi piace avere tea che
personaggio corrispondete scrivetelo nei
commenti
prenderemo store non mettetevi comodi
alla fine del video scrivete sì qual è
stato il vostro gioco preferito spero mi
sia detto senza aggravante la data
seguirlo ea ridotto resta iniziamo
subito con il primo il primo giorno di
richiamo ascheri e visti praticamente
super una sorta di copia di carrie
fisher svedese quella mondo è una
spiriti c'era un po di berta secondo me
però ha vestito bello rispetto a
scrivere e poi qua possiamo scegliere il
personaggio è molto spesso di spiriti
derenik però questa non e tani primo
scherzo metti un regalo immagino per
questa finta feriti share alle entrate
della porta a lei si chiama miss julie
distruggerai la giornata con questo
regalo scherzo eccola rubiamo che sta
facendo la faccia è un po arrabbiata
vediamo un po come la casa di mister
giuliani ha una casa e per allora c'è
scritto che devo trovare il regalo
vicino all'entrata forse che questo
presa da scatola ora lo devo mettere
vicino ad entrarvi che noi prima di
essere scoperto da scritti luce ok mezzo
a suonare il campanello che sappiamo
vediamo vediamo vediamo
[Musica]
allora messi jolie si sta addormentando
quindi mettiamo un po di formaggio nel
suo letto così arriveranno i topi
ecco lo vediamo fa andando a dormire
[Risate]
hai visto come stava dormendo
allora mio trovare il formaggio al piano
di sopra nella cucina che bella casa che
a miss julie saracini fasi di un teschio
nel radar sopra in questo gioco stile
spiriti sono invece di avere la camera
su sulla maestra cattiva abbiamo la
camera tipo un radar con la mappa lì se
il test di un cazzo che stai spezia dove
l'ha mai arrivato no ma lei svegliato un
uomo
parte sbagliata ma quanti ok sarà
iniziato le già lì non c'è bisogno a
dormire ma non stavo già dormendo dai
sbrighiamocì prendiamo il forno che
dobbiamo andare a trovare la stanza
attento che lei mi sa che sta ancora
pagando nel corridoio a giudicare dal
teschio nel rogers e il teschio quindi
lei si sta avvicinando qua penso che
magari sta dormendo
[Musica]
forse sono fatto mai saltato né
scavalcata tornando ma chi cucina prova
speriamo che ora lei dormiva in camera
da letto e ci deve scappare però dalla
casa non devi uscire fuori dalla casa
trenta secondi
puoi farcela se sei riuscito a
scavalcarlo e poi posizione a scappare i
piedi prossimo scherzo mi son
dimenticato di dirvi alla fine del video
lo scrive the seas qual è il gioco che
vi è piaciuto più di tutti e magari
diamo un gioco da 1 a 10 11 chiediamo ma
per ora 10 ogni gioco anche allora il
prossimo scherzo miss julie sta dormendo
sostanza ma sempre momento di prendere
uno scheletro dall'asta ecco la piccola
non momenti andando a dormire
comunque questo scherzo cattivissimo
mettere lo scheletro bellezza giacche a
vento operiamo che non ci mostri le
mutande qualche volta ma allora lo
scheletro e al piano di sopra
andiamo senza farsi scoprire si sta
andando in camera da letto ma che è
successo in questa stanza
eccola qui lo scheletro feriti forse
arrabbiata smonta scheletro perché è
arrossito ma soprattutto che cosa è di
paolo mariani tra la casa tua
una maestra di scienza e magari allo
scheletro dentro casa lo speriamo sia
questo il mood anticamera speed giusto
eccola con liquore del divano nel finale
non potevo scappare a scopare scappare
lì dov'è k
non mi vogliono la porta mi ha preso
ok abbiamo ricominciato il livello
abbiamo già preso lo scheletro speriamo
di riuscirci questa volta sta per
scadere il tempo per fregarci non se n'è
accorto e stavo dietro di lei nutre
corta ma che sta facendo bene dice che
abbiamo completato il livello sul
reazione era un po strano vediamo questo
gioco 18 perché altri che non è
divertente ma che fa gli scherzi alla
maestra anche se non voglio vedere
mutando 7 dalla fine era carino
grazie e gioca una grandissima richiesta
torna verso al mom la mamma cattiva
virtuale vediamo c'è scritto c'è un
cucciolo fuori dalla casa devianza amori
e giocare con il cagnolino che il
bambino ha detto che è il caso lo sta
guardando e sta pensando anche il cane
pensa che ho studiato trovata ho vinto
io di un appalto andiamo a giocare con
il cane stiamo attenzione si arrabbierà
usa ha detto ecco dunque dobbiamo
portare
[Musica]
andiamo cattiva virtuale cari ciao non
sia una stanza dei videogiochi al piano
di sopra devi andare dove c'è l'xbox è
il giocare a qualsiasi gioco sono sicura
che la mamma del quale si arrabbia non
paghiamo più giovani e molto caldo
eccola ok lei adesso che prima dobbiamo
andare a studiare forte dopo ci farò
giocare dice di andare al piano di sopra
e giocare lo stesso problema allora
dobbiamo andare su nella stanza dei
videogiochi i tre ventole da pochi non
c'è la bomba carta
ecco c'è una chiave cielo chiave
dobbiamo trovarla
non s'è visto ragioni strato vita eccolo
e così abbiamo ripreso inseriti griffate
livello questa è la nostra cameretta
sempre che non ci sia
[Musica]
20 00 ragazzi di giocare allora dobbiamo
accendere l'interruttore purtroppo
prossimo livello dobbiamo andare nella
stanza di giochi e giocare a biliardo
fumetti ecco la cia è viva ha detto come
ti aspetti di avere successo nella vita
se non studi allora adesso dobbiamo
stare super attenti perché qui c'è il
padre non abbiamo bisogno di trovare la
chiave
se questa vediamo e proprio lì e allora
noi usciamo di qua così riusciamo
dall'esterno entriamo dalla finestra
bene ottimo se non sbaglio abbiamo visto
una scala qui vediamo riconoscano e così
siamo da qui direttamente questa volta
non si beccherà la mamma mi rifarò il
padre mi portò se l'abbiamo morto
vediamo se ci scoprire se volete che
continuiamo con i prossimi livelli la
mamma virtuale ma ora passiamo all ex
fidanzato o marito di scary teachers
curry pro.ber prossimo gioco l'ex marito
ex fidanzato di superficie si fa che
scritti c'era un sacco di bilancio
abbiamo
pane di leone di san valentino anche
parker i rover vediamo un po come questa
siamo allora dice di rovinare
l'appuntamento di felix the letter
fidanzata allora che cosa è successo
uno dei ladri non si chiama l'estero
face comunque fanno l ex marito di
spiriti suoi scritti serve destino
chissà come reagirebbe portato a casa la
tua fidanzata è rappresentata slavica
solo che il suo amico tra innamorati
sono fidanzata e glielo pone rubare e
quindi destava tipo cantando una canzone
e lui ha detto si è arrabbiato e deluso
e arrabbiato e avendo bella impressione
rho cucinando nella mia torta speciale
quindi noi ora dobbiamo fare uno scherzo
a questi due ladri e cioè dobbiamo
prendere questo topolino paperino quindi
se dire stringerla
ok abbiamo ricominciato che bello questo
perché siamo fuori bellissimo io ho
fatto delle cose strane se vorrebbe la
camera di sicurezza non è stato sempre
facendo qualcosa di strano allora che
cosa dobbiamo fare abbiamo sbagliato
prima stava un messaggio è il tuo film
lavatrice prima che il cavo con
arrivando perché senza rumori brano che
alta con questa musica di sottofondo
bush allora per prima cosa allora
sistemiamo il cavo ed in effetti qui
perché c'è questa musica l'azione di
sottofondo
ok abbiamo poter mettere i fumatrice sa
che sta per i membri o impossibile come
chiuderà la porta
ok lava tornato perché fa perché
dobbiamo restringere il topolino tocca
perché era troppo grande e così adesso
lo possiamo nascondere meglio forse no
ok ok siamo in cucina dove lo mettiamo
nella torta la torta è qui però abbiamo
bisogno di un coltello
anzi no prima la sportiamo
anche trovare il portello però aiuta
stai cercando voglio fare voglio fare e
il freddo degli astri sono della
cappella perso praticamente sto
utilizzando il latte alla terra per fare
una specie di mal tipo cemento per
sporcare il topolino
no è molto più difficile di scary teaser
presto proprio uscire fuori poiché
riesco a farlo fuori e abbiamo capito
come dobbiamo fare dobbiamo prima
pensare occupata su del topo e poi
lanciare la foto la così mettiamo sopra
quelli in palio fatto così non si
riconosca dietro riusciamo mimetizzarla
nella torta cinghiale si è anche
diventato marroncino gli si che dobbiamo
trovare qualcosa per tagliare la torta e
poi un coltello preso devo a tagliare la
torta
siamo abbiamo così fatto o che ne dite
mettiamo il topolino che lo scafa che
fare scappare via degli stati un mi
piace se volete che continuiamo quegli
scherzi
ieri roba paese è stato preferito a
questo secondo è stato troppo divertente
fare di darti per me il primo perché
poteva dormire invece il vostro perfino
possono sapere nei commenti
e ora andate a vedere gli altri episodi
gameplay oppure inoltre gli altri video
cliccate una nipote cartelline e buona
visione